people love to tell me that I got lucky
it makes me so angry because I didn't I
was buying for years when everybody was
scared I bought so much Bitcoin in
November 2022 when the market crashed
when Bitcoin crashed all the way down to
$115,000 remember this is at a time when
FTX ran off with everybody's money the
whole Market was crumbling Celsius block
fire they all went bankrupt everybody
was terrified but I bought Bitcoin I
bought it at $155,000 when everybody was
scared but it doesn't matter people
still tell me that I got lucky even
though it's not luck it's bravery it's
conviction and understanding in what
this technology is and knowing that one
day it's going to be worth a lot more
than $155,000